Speaker 1: while we are doing the Mike Pillow arc.
I do want to just briefly, I'm not going to spend
a lot of time on this, but I do want to briefly
follow up on something. There's a new deadline
for Mike Pillow. Mike Pillow says that finally
praise Jesus. The Trump fraud case will be filed,
I guess, on November 23rd. Now that's, I guess,
the day before a day or two before next week's
Thanksgiving holiday in the United States. As a
refresher, if you forgot, blocked it out, which I
would understand haven't been paying attention.
MyPillow CEO Mike Lindell has been predicting
Trump's reinstatement for a very long time. First,
it was going to be December of 2021, where the
win would be given to Trump, and it was going to
be by January 6th. We know how that turned out,
and it was going to be by the day of Joe Biden's
inauguration in later January. By March, April,
Trump was going to be back. The Supreme Court was
going to take a case. Mike Pillow seems not to
know that cases get appealed to the Supreme Court.
He seems to be in the mindset that I guess Judge
Kavanaugh might be like, Bring me the case, bring
me. I'm taking a break. Just bring a case to me.
Then it was going to be. Trump would be
back in office by the end of August. That's
two months ago, three months ago at this point.
The new deadline is that some kind of mysterious
legal team and unclear internal research
combined with I don't even know what else
is going to lead to and ahead of schedule. Case,
presumably in the Supreme Court. Mike Pillow
doesn't say what's the legal mechanism that would
allow the Supreme Court to just take action on
random claims of election fraud? None of it makes
any sense. But here is Mike Pillow at. Reawaken
America from American Faith, another one of these
religious events, take a listen to this show.
Speaker 4: So that's getting that's getting
filed a week from Tuesday. It's this thick.
It's different. It's not what was filed before.
Speaker 1: OK, so there's a new thing.
Extremely thick. Maybe wide. I don't know. It's
going to be filed. It's different. And then
I guess the Supreme Court takes it up. And
by the way, you see one guy right behind
pillow raising his fist in adulation and glee and
stuff like that. Do you think people even believe
pillow when he says this stuff, like when they
cheer and they go, Oh, do they even believe it?
And it's just comedy at this point in time? It's
it is. It is just worthless. Substantively, it's
just comedy. My curiosity is, at what point does
Pillow actually just say it's not going to happen?
We just got to reelect him in 2024. What? How,
how smooth will that transition be? Let me know
what you think. We'll take a quick break and
be back with more stories right after this.